it was a holiday cruise ship which
became one of the biggest single
clusters of coronavirus the outbreak of
kovat 19 on the diamond princess in
Japan has infected more than 700 people
and taken six lives among them the first
Briton to be killed by the virus the man
became ill after being quarantined with
thousands of others on board
he'd been receiving treatment at a
Japanese hospital before he died in a
statement this evening the Prime
Minister defended a decision not to
evacuate British passengers from the
ship sooner we were following the best
medical advice and I obviously I'm we
regret any we very much regret the loss
of life of the individual concern but
you know we think that the best thing to
do is not to move people around too much
there are bad at least for British
citizens are still in Japan after
contracting the virus among them David
and Sally Abel who tested positive hours
before the quarantine period was due to
end were both positive okay we both
tested positive for the virus the
diamond princess left Yokohama in Japan
on the 20th of January a dream cruise
including stops in China Vietnam and
Taiwan on the 1st of February it was
confirmed an 8 year old passenger who
disembarked in Hong Kong had tested
positive for coronavirus on the 4th of
February Japanese health inspectors
asked for 24 hours to test passengers
and the ship was put into lockdown for
14 days
despite the quarantine the number of
infections continued to rise
Alan Steele was the first Briton to be
diagnosed with the virus on board
speaking to Sky News after he left
hospital he said it was a worrying time
first time I near the caster's after
I've been swap tested
couple days later I got a phone call
saying they were coming to collect me
the anxiety's any calluses and not
knowing no one tell me anything and the
language barrier in the hope of stopping
the spread many passengers didn't leave
their cabins for 17 days but it was too
late well you think what a cruise ship
is it's a load of people got together in
a relatively small space in quite high
density so those are conditions doesn't
matter where it is the aid transmission
of infection is the legacy of this
outbreak is still being felt as another
life is lost to the virus
Siobhan Robbins Sky News